this week's 48 hours investigates the
death of an alabama woman with an
active following on a site known for its
adult content
cat west posted suggested pictures of
herself for her
only fan subscribers who pay to see
exclusive pictures and videos
police and scoured her social media
accounts for possible clues
after her body was found outside her
home 48 hours correspondent maureen
maher takes us inside the case
catwest was not your average
stay-at-home mom
she put the social in social media her
only fans account had
hundreds of subscribers it's sort of the
happy medium between
porn and the brady bunch the case caught
the attention of reporter and
cbs news consultant carol robinson
the partially dressed body of a woman
was found
outside of her home in an alabama suburb
she'd suffered a head injury and the
scene appeared to be staged
a bottle of absinthe was propped up on
her cell phone
that bottle was placed on the phone like
this she learned kat west whose fans
knew her as
kitty cat west had a husband jeff and a
daughter lola
family friend brittany dreissler says
the west
were an unlikely couple i know opposites
attract but
i was like that guy pulled that girl
you would not describe this as a
conventional marriage definitely not
she says cat was a flamboyant marilyn
monroe devotee
jeff was a former army recruiter
buttoned down and squared away
police sergeant mike melhoff says at the
scene he was
oddly reserved everybody grieves in a
different way
that was something i kept telling myself
jeff told police they had gone to dinner
that night
and then stopped to buy liquor on the
way home where he had photographed kat
for her online fans
you never saw an ounce of jealousy from
him never
never police wondered if one of her
internet fans could have killed her we
were concerned that you know do we have
somebody
out there that's actually killing people
they say they scoured cats online
accounts
but didn't find any viable suspects
on february 22nd 2018
william jeffrey west the victim's
husband has been arrested and charged
with the murder
defense attorney john robbins there was
nothing on his clothes
no liquor no blood no bodily fluid no
tissue no hair
did you ever consider the possibility
that maybe this guy just
snapped one night but there's no
evidence to that i mean he does not have
a history of violence jeff could not
have possibly done it
had you heard of only fans no ma'am
there's
a lot of things i learned in this case
welcome to only fans
and maureen maher joins us now maureen i
think a lot of people are hearing for
the first time about only
fans but it does raise the question of
how social media impacts an
investigation like this
tony it certainly complicates it as the
lead investigator told us
when you have a suspect or usually one
or two that they're looking at in a case
but now you're talking about thousands
of online contacts that cat west had
they have to go through each and every
one of them
but on the larger social media platforms
you're also talking about thousands of
people who are commenting
and calling police trying to help with
their investigation
it sounds like a difficult investigation
maureen maher thank you very much and
you can see maureen's
full report the mysterious death of cat
west on 48 hours saturday at 10
9 central right here on cbs